now I grew up Trichy did you know that I
did learn that and I did too we went to
church three times a week I thought you
were about to say we went to church
together I'm so sorry
you went to church three times a week
twice on Sunday once on Wednesday and
then once I got confirmed then we had
youth group which meant once a month
that sounds better
yeah well I mean we still went to church
three times a week I didn't go to
religious destruction every week that
sounds something worse what did you grow
up super like kind of you know a
straight and narrow I did like I was
kind of the good girl
um and I didn't start drinking until I
turned 21 but I look but everybody else
had been drinking forever
rats yeah me too okay 21 yeah aftershock
it but cinnamon liqueur but by the time
it's for ladies but yeah but I started
with like the trash like st. Ives
they're gonna hate with it Saint I did a
show so it's not a side cisco's a
supermarket just Cisco the fungi oh
there's Cisco and we and we used to play
drinking games and when we drank it um
the after point you start to get like
paralyzed have you ever experienced that
like you get a little bit tub that's how
bad it was
you drink a point where you couldn't
move well yeah my your arms would feel
really weird and then it would wear off
who gave you this drink we bought it
ghetto shop around the corner so you get
so buzzed that you you would be comatose
we're just just a little bit like you
felt like I have the same experience
with champagne with cheap champagne yeah
like I get that weird like uh I can't
move my arms and then it wears off and
then I'm back at it one of the things
that I find when I'm getting older is
that I hurt myself a lot more easily
like I'll sleep I'll sleep wrong like
it'll be like I got it yeah you hurt
yourself I was yeah
and I was in the bathroom in the
lavatory of a airplane and it's very
important that women wipe front to back
front to back from the back front to
back and I pulled my shoulder it was you
know it's like tight out like bathrooms
in on the airplane it's already very
tight and I'm you know you're trying not
to sit and you're balancing and it's
like and I was like did you hit a flight
attendant but me no I just patted myself
try and wash my hands and was bitter for
the rest of the fly
I can't even told that story enough that
he would say please tell it on the show
yeah then he was like please tell the
story of you wiping properly in a tight
space and hurting yourself permanently
hurt does it still hurt no no but I do
have a wonky shoulder and I think I get
it from my dad my dad has some shoulder
issues so I think it was preexisting you
should talk to your dad and be like dad
you ever been anything how about a round
bustard right everybody
we come back